[Música]
este jueves 11 de mayo a la medianoche
expira el llamado título 42 miles de
migrantes intentan cruzar a territorio
estadounidense antes del fin de la
medida Washington teme una situación
caótica y reitera que su frontera no
está abierta
México celebró este miércoles 10 de mayo
el día de las madres durante el día
cientos de ellas acompañadas también por
sus familias marcharon por las calles de
Ciudad de México para recordar a sus
hijos e hijas desaparecidos Por quienes
siguen pidiendo justicia
y el gobierno de Nicaragua canceló la
personería jurídica de la Cruz Roja
argumentando una supuesta falta de
neutralidad durante las protestas de
2018 la organización sin ánimo de lucro
pasará a ser un ente adscrito al
Ministerio de salud
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos el Informativo
en la frontera entre Estados Unidos y
México el presidente de Estados Unidos
Joe biden pronosticó que esta frontera
Se volverá caótica ante la llegada
masiva de migrantes cuando está a punto
de expirar el título 42 la medida que
permitía las expulsiones rápidas
alegando motivos de salud pública se
espera que el gobierno de Joe biden
publique una nueva Norma que pondría más
condiciones para otorgar asilo y Estados
como Texas y Florida dominados por
republicanos radicalizan sus posturas
frente a los indocumentados
el tiempo para el título 42 se acaba a
poco más de 24 horas de que caduque la
medida miles de migrantes intentan
cruzar a territorio estadounidense el
hecho genera esperanza y confusión pero
la posición de la Casa Blanca
es Clara
permítanme ser claro el levantamiento de
la orden de salud pública del título 42
no significa que nuestra frontera esté
abierta de hecho es todo lo contrario el
uso que hacemos de nuestras autoridades
de control de la emigración en virtud
del título octavo del código de Estados
Unidos implica consecuencias más duras
para las personas que cruzan la frontera
ilegalmente
los temores de que hasta 10.000
migrantes por día traten de cruzar la
frontera han dado impulso a los Estados
más conservadores en Texas el gobernador
grega a botín formó que envió a más de
17,000 migrantes a ciudades gobernadas
por demócratas como Nueva York
Washington DC Chicago o Filadelfia el
gobernador de Florida ronde santis
promulgó una ley que entre otros efectos
prohíbe que los inmigrantes en situación
irregular obtengan credenciales de
identidad conduzcan automóviles incluso
con licencias de otros estados y obliga
a las empresas a utilizar el sistema de
eBay un software que comprueba el
estatus migratorio de los trabajadores
nadie tiene derecho a emigrar a este
país ningún extranjero nosotros
determinamos Cómo estadounidenses Qué
tipo de sistema de inmigración beneficia
a nuestro país pero cuando se hace
inmigración no es En beneficio de ellos
como extranjeros es para su beneficio
como estadounidenses
de cara al fin del título 42 heredado de
la era Trump la administración de Joe
biden promulgaría una ley A última hora
del jueves que impediría solicitar asilo
en Estados Unidos a quienes no lo hayan
hecho en los países que previamente
transitaron también en Estados Unidos
George Santos congresista republicano Se
declaró inocente por los 13 cargos
federales que pesan en su contra y quedó
en Libertad bajo una fianza de medio
millón de dólares se le acusó de fraude
malversación y robo de fondos públicos a
pesar de los múltiples llamados el
político se niega de emitir de la cámara
de representantes
se ha declarado inocente pero George
Santos congresista republicano fue
detenido el miércoles imputado por
fraude y blanqueo de capitales tras
tejer supuestamente una red de mentiras
que asombró incluso a los políticos a
más duros del Capitolio los fiscales
federales lo acusan de fraude sus
contribuyentes para usar los fondos en
ropa de lujo y pagos con tarjeta de
crédito también por cobrar prestaciones
por desempleo que no le correspondían y
por mentir al congreso acerca de ser
millonario aunque muchos legisladores
republicanos ya han pedido a Santos que
renuncie los líderes de la cámara
insisten en que es inocente hasta que se
demuestre su culpabilidad hay un proceso
legal acabamos de ver algunos de ellos
esta mañana en Estados Unidos hay una
presunción de inocencia pero son cargos
serios tendrá que pasar por el proceso
legal pero vamos a seguir trabajando
para erradicar el fraude Santos fue
elegido para el congreso a finales del
año pasado después de una campaña basada
en gran parte en mentiras afirmó haber
en firmas de Wall Street de alto perfil
como goldman Sax y City Group Santos
también dijo que había sido un jugador
estrella de voleibol en la universidad y
había alimentado su campaña con riquezas
hechas a sí mismo Pero en realidad no
trabajó en Wall Street no fue a la
universidad y tuvo problemas financieros
antes de postularse para el cargo podría
enfrentar hasta 20 años de prisión si es
declarado culpable
este miércoles 10 de mayo se celebró
México el día de las madres una fecha en
la que muchas de ellas salieron también
a marchar en Ciudad de México lo
hicieron Para recordar que miles de
hijos desaparecidos siguen teniendo voz
y rostro pese a desconocerse su paradero
más de 112.000 personas llenan la lista
de desaparecidos en México una cifra que
sigue aumentando en medio de una nueva
oleada de violencia en el país
Somos la voz
y representamos en cada uno de sus
rostros
la vida la imagen de nuestros hijos pero
gritaron la sociedad con nuestros hijos
tienen un rostro tienen una vida tienen
una familia
que los esperas que ansia tenerlos de
regreso no podemos callar nos vamos
hasta Nicaragua en donde el gobierno
sandinista y sus aliados aprobaron
cancelar la personería jurídica y
embargar los bienes y patrimonio de la
Cruz Roja del país que pasarán a manos
del Estado también será el estado quien
administre ahora esta organización con
65 años de historia en Nicaragua el
gobierno de Daniel Ortega acusa a la
Cruz Roja de haber actuado en contra de
los principios de humanidad
imparcialidad y neutralidad durante las
protestas antigubernamentales de hace
cinco años que dejaron cientos de
muertos
el patrimonio
bienes y
acción que a la fecha pertenezcan
a la asociación nacional llamada Cruz
Roja nicaragüense
pasarán a ser propiedad del estado y
serán administrados por la Cruz Roja
nicaragüense
ente descentralizado
adscrito al Ministerio de salud
minsa y Ecuador anunció la mayor
conversión de deuda por protección de la
naturaleza realizada jamás en la
historia el procedimiento financiero
reduce pasivo y genera un ahorro
millonario destinado a la conservación
de las Islas Galápagos sobre el canje de
deuda más grande en el mundo para un
negocio que rinde frutos Ecuador canjeó
parte de su deuda por naturaleza por
medio de una operación financiera que le
permitirá reducir sus obligaciones y
ahorrar millones de dólares que ahora
dedicará la conservación Ha logrado el
canje de deuda por conservación más
grande de la historia de la humanidad
generando un ahorro de mil cien millones
de dólares al servicio de la deuda
con ello
450 millones de dólares se invertirán en
la protección de uno de los ecosistemas
más increíbles del planeta las Islas
Galápagos el movimiento respaldado por
el banco interamericano de desarrollo y
Estados Unidos combina diferentes e
innovadores instrumentos de mejora
crediticia y se convierte en un ejemplo
de soluciones a desafíos globales en
materia ambiental esto significa que se
ha canjeado deuda actual por un valor
aproximado de
1630 millones de dólares por una nueva
deuda de 656 millones de dólares en
términos sencillos esto sería como
comprar un dólar por 40 centavos
los canjes de deuda por naturaleza
fueron populares en los años 80 durante
la crisis de deuda de América Latina
cuando los países dejaban de destinar
dinero a la protección ambiental
hoy resurgen como una oportunidad tras
una nueva crisis provocada por la
pandemia la mayor conversión de deuda
por naturaleza del mundo permitirá a
Ecuador proteger a perpetuidad esta
reserva compuesta por 13 Islas que son
el hogar de 3.500 especies el 25% de
ellas catalogadas como especies
endémicas
la fiscalía del estado de goyaz en
Brasil acusó a 16 personas Incluyendo a
siete futbolistas profesionales de
arreglar partidos como parte de un
presunto esquema relacionado con
apuestas ilegales el central del Santos
Eduardo vawaman ya apartado del equipo
está acusado de haber recibido Diez mil
dólares por ser amonestado con una
tarjeta amarilla en un duelo del año
pasado el Ministerio Público Estatal
tiene bajo la mira 13 encuentros de la
primera y la Segunda División del fútbol
brasileño ocho de ellos jugados En 2022
hoy otros cuatro equipos apartaron a
cinco futbolistas que están investigados
más no imputados hasta aquí este
informativo sigan conectados a France 24
[Música]